is man Abdul Rahman. I'm teacher. Uh I
want to ask something uh to Zakir Naik.
I have reach uh I have read a hadith
about
how it can be heaven uh without military
means.
He has heard the
>> how how how
Islam can reach to Rome.
>> So the hadith says how Islam can reach
Rome.
>> Yeah. Uh yes. How Islam can reach uh to
Rome without uh use military mean.
>> Thanks doctor.
>> So if you heard he has heard the hadith
which says uh Islam will reach room. So
he's asking how can Islam reach room
without war and without
>> brother leave hadith
>> the Quranic verse there's a full
surah of the Quran surah room have you
read the Quran
>> yes
>> chapter number 30 room
>> full surah and the starting of the surah
says that the Muslims will defeat the
Romans
>> leave us at the hadith the Quran says
history says that Muslim defeated the
Roman so why you saying we cannot go to
Rome
That mean you don't know history.
Correct.
>> You read the Quran, it's a prophecy of
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam that
Muslim will repeat the Romes in certain
years and maximum is 9 years. And after
he said that within 9 years the Muslim
defeated the Romes,
>> the Romans,
>> how can it uh happen and it reach?
>> How can it happen? Already happened
>> without without military means.
>> It was their military wife. He went
there brother you don't know history
what can I do
>> with with jihad
>> Muslim went yes
>> yes
>> Muslim there he went there military wise
we won the battle and we were victorious
correct